Bianca is with us in New Mexico hey
Bianca how are you yeah how are you
better than I deserve what's up all
right so my husband and I we're in the
middle of baby step number two we just
finished paying off 13,000 to our active
debt and now we're looking at 20,000 in
collections my question is how do I go
about how do I go about this do I list
it smallest to largest what do I need to
tackle first it's a little bit it's a
little bit complicated but I think you
let me walk you through what I suggest
you're doing let's see if we can get
there together okay so you don't have
any active debt at all you're not paying
payments on any of these collections no
good and how old are the collections so
all this is about nine years and the
youngest it's taxes so it's current
probably I don't know about a year tax
is like IRS yeah well it's not buyers
it's the state tax and how much is it
eight hundred okay pay that one then
we'll move on we don't want to do what
we do not deal with the government okay
they got a lot of power and their fees
and their interest rates are ridiculous
so just get that one done now we'll move
on to the rest of them so the others are
what's the next youngest one um that's
probably it the other ones were probably
all done within the same time maybe uh
all eight or nine years old yeah what
kind of dad are they so there's phone
bills there's one credit card and then
there's to repossess cars okay all right
so the bulk of this is the repos yeah
okay repos will take somewhere around
ten to fifteen cents on the dollar
especially if they're that old okay okay
so we're not talking about $20,000 here
we're talking about seven thousand bucks
is gonna clear this whole thing probably
yeah okay
now here's what we're gonna do the first
thing we're gonna do is list them
smallest largest we get rid of tax bill
that one's gone they list the rest of
them smallest to largest and you're
going to call
have the money in the account saved up
to pay what you think the balance was
back when okay okay all right and so
let's use an example let's just pull
that a credit card what's the credit
card one the credit card is 664 664
dollars yeah and what's your household
income well it's the last year we
brought in eighty thousand however my
husband does pay $800 a month in child
support okay I would go to that credit
card and say the last information I have
is I owed you 664 if he will accept 664
I will send you a check today if you
will give it to me in writing that that
is to confirm balance I wouldn't
negotiate with one that's small okay
okay let's say there's one of the one of
the deficit one of the deficits on the
repo okay and it's showing what so the
smallest one is 7800 okay that's a good
example all right
you would call them up and maybe you've
got two thousand dollars saved at this
point before you call them okay you call
them up and say I got two thousand
dollars you want it if you want it I'll
give it to you a settlement in full on
this and they say yeah we can't do that
we can't do that
listen I have another car repo here and
I have another credit card here and I
have a whole bunch of stuff from nine
years ago and I'm trying to go through
and clean them up and the first one that
takes my money is gonna get my money I
got $2,000 do you want it if not I'm
moving to the next person on the list
and see if they want it okay
is that me saying you want is that you
saying you want me go the next list
because right quick for a hang up I want
to make sure because if you want this
it's yours I won't call anybody else and
we'll do a deal right now but if you
want me to call the next guy on the list
I will cuz that's what you're gonna do
you're gonna call the next on the list
it's not a bluff yeah okay and
eventually you'll have to beat around
and go around the barn and yo-yo-yo-yo
and all the garbage they go through
because you know you're not dealing with
intelligent life usually when you're
talking to these people and so you
finally get it nailed down whatever the
amount is that you settle on that
they're going to accept and you're then
you have that much money don't make them
a promise if you don't have the money
okay but you're gonna settle on that
amount and let's say it's $2,200 okay
send that to me in writing and I will
respond to you as soon as I get it in
writing instantaneously with payment so
two rules you do not have a deal if it's
not in writing you can tell the people
in this industry are lying if their
mouth is moving you do not have a deal
if it's not in writing that's rule
number one got it got it
you gotta even if it's a paying off the
balance you're showing in front of you
on a nine year old one you got to verify
they'll accept that amount as the
payment for that debt that's six sixty
four whatever you got to get it in
writing
it didn't happen if it's not writing you
pay them $664 they're gonna send you a
bill for six thousand dollars in back
payments and interest okay and you're
going to start over again with them so
get it in writing that they're gonna
take what the balance was what you're
showing the balance or whatever it is in
writing second rule is no never can
people like this have electronic access
to your checking account it's okay to
have your electric bill or something
like that come out your checking account
do not let these people have your
checking account they will lie and they
will clean you out it happens all the
time to people were coaching happens
quite often disturbingly often so how do
we pay them then well you can pay them
with a prepaid debit card that just has
the exact amount on it that you owe them
in that one account then you cut that
one up throw it away and get another one
and do one for each one of these there's
not that many of them you can have a
separate checking account that you do
allow them to have access in but any
amount of money that is in that account
is in danger so don't put more in there
than you've agreed to because they'll
take it and then what are you gonna do
because you owed them more than you were
settled for even though you got the
settlement writing you'll go before the
judge and go they promised to settle you
end up spending ten thousand dollars
trying to chase - so now get it in
writing and no electronic access to your
checking account under any circumstances
and that'll do it for you